i cannot believe
that we lost brian stelter and liz
cheney in the same week
american democracy is dead my friend
you know it actually took me a lot of
practice to be able to say that without
breaking out into laughing i was it was
really easy for me to tweet that but
ladies and gentlemen brian stelter's out
he was fired from cnn well okay i know
he was fired but they canceled his show
which basically means he's fired i guess
the entire staff gone
rumors are now circulating we're hearing
that jim acosta may be next in line with
the next couple of weeks it may even be
don lemon who is out cnn cnn is
collapsing and
you know
on tuesday just two days ago liz cheney
lost her primary and we were all just so
excited to see the establishment crumble
to see now these moves made against cnn
it's a uh we're going into the midterms
and i just got to warn everybody don't
sit back thinking you got it in the bag
because this is what they're trying to
lull you into a false sense of security
look at all these good things
you know we got to make sure that we we
go in we get all our friends out we go
and vote so we'll talk about that plus
donald trump the madman has endorsed
democrats fulfilling the prophecy
the babylon bee wrote that in a genius
move donald trump endorses or supports
impeachment forcing democrats to oppose
donald trump has now endorsed the
democrat who led the impeachment charge
against him and other democrats have
taken the bait no joke they're acting
like he literally endorsed democrats
this is amazing what a ridiculous time
to be alive ladies and gentlemen before
we get started head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
directly and you'll get access to our
exclusive shows on tim cast tonight at
11 p.m we're gonna have a members only
uncensored tim cast after show that'll
be up on the website the members only
section and we've got cass castle tales
of the inverted world more to come so
don't forget to also smash that like
button right now subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
joining us tonight to talk about all
this and more is mike glover
what's going on who are you mike glover
nobody really is important i mean just
i'm just a guy
not some guy yeah so i i'm um a former
special operations guy
i'm also a contractor for the cia um
i also own a company called field craft
survival that teaches preparedness
and everything uh anything revolving a a
worst-case scenario to citizen situation
awareness tactical training the list
goes on
and then uh i've been recently canceled
as you know so hold on you're quite
literally a fed i am a bootlegger
according to a lot of people but wait no
here's am i going to say that blue
liquor yeah but but they also accuse you
of being being an extremist yes so on
one side
yeah there's a so there's an article
that was released when i started this
group called american contingency which
is like a community group based on the
blm and antifa activities which you're
very familiar with i mean it's one of
the reasons why
a lot of these things have evolved out
of that that's the good that came out of
the bad and i started this american
contingency idea
of just pulling people together doing
what a special operation sergeant major
would do like hey let's let's leverage
our assets and do something positive
here and then i was called immediately a
right-wing extremist and white
nationalist which is crazy because i
identify as an asian guy and um and so
well to clarify you're quite literally
an asian guy i'm quite literally a six
foot one asian man
uh which is rare but um i i'm half
korean my dad was in the army met my mom
in korea when he was stationed there and
i took offense to this but i could do
nothing because all the platforms
canceled me facebook instagram
i fought to get those back and got a
couple of them back but not before usa
today advertised the entire article that
was written by obviously a leftist
journalist who was who had an agenda
cnn reached out to me reached out to me
and said hey we want to talk to you
because they were running a piece on
proud boys
talked to me for an hour and realized oh
this dude's just a normal guy who's
trying to run a business and and be
positive in his community they move past
that and then of recent project veritas
released this document that said
american contingency is a militia
violent extremist organization a banner
for all of these white nationalist and
domestic extremists so that's crazy it's
crazy because i'm not any of that people
who know me i'm very moderate and i'm
not on the fringes of anything because
that's just not her role wow all right
we'll talk about that man thanks for
commenting yeah thank you we got hannah
claire bremerlo hanging out hi i'm
hankler brimlaw i'm a writer for this
cool news site called timcast.com it is
pretty cool it's the coolest i'm uh ian
crossan and a wild wizard sometimes i
wonder why am i here and then i realize
it's the cast magic that's right no it's
just to be cool
if you guys watched cass castle you'll
see me walk in and you'll get a full
view of the table and i just point out
that it's just i don't know what's going
on with this mess you guys gotta look at
these gems this is an aquamarine not
only does he have a ton of gems but he
has a miniature version of himself that
is awesome i didn't choose that that
just appeared someone said that just
appeared
in here that's weird like when people
laud love and adulation on you like
don't don't like don't fall for it but
don't don't deny it ian came in here in
the middle of the night and put that
little e in there yeah show that you
know show the little ian's trying to
make himself seem more mysterious
so cute
yeah ian has one of those and i also
have one of those but she lives at home
tim has one too that has a little
skateboard very hard to balance but we
appreciate whoever made those make those
for us
all right let's get into it all right
the first big story from timcast.com
brian stelter to leave cnn reliable
sources cancelled
the media analysis show has been on the
air since 1993 i didn't realize that
yeah they they put brian selter on that
show no he has a predecessor uh so his
predecessor is a man named howard kurtz
and he eventually left cnn he left uh
reliable sources to go on to be with fox
who he's still with today but so so
brian seltzer is given this show and
then burns it to the ground and destroys
the legacy of a 30 year old show and i
think this whole uh this story for me is
interesting because it's a web you can
see where everyone comes from brian
seltzer he came from the new york times
and then they moved to fox media like
everyone is so interconnected in this
world that like incestuous yes that's a
great word for it media incest yeah and
so to a certain extent i know there's
been some speculation about where he'll
go next uh and that's why i think
companies like ours and platforms like
youtube are so interesting because they
disrupt this uh
member sharing that so you're saying we
should we should hire brian stelter yes
only if i
retain my rank as senior reporter and he
has to start as a junior staffer i
didn't say as a reporter we got some we
got some garbage he wants to hang out
with the chickens we got chickens he can
kim can train him i love it i think it's
great look he's you know
i i'm uh reluctant often to be so crass
in reference to people but this guy is
is seriously one of the worst in media
no matter what happens he's he always
finds a way into weaseling some kind of
shill defense for the establishment no
matter what they do even going as far as
to tell people not to watch other
propaganda networks only watch us
i get it if you know if you're dependent
on ratings you want to convince
everybody just keep watching us keep
watching us but if you want to be honest
about the idea of spreading truth and
doing journalism then what we say here
is oh you should watch other shows you
should watch the left you should watch
the right you should watch cnn fox news
determine for yourself who you think is
telling the truth and who you can trust
yeah i think a sign of greatness and
confidence is when you you encourage
other people to go experience other
things other than you and then because
they do and they trust you and they find
out that their life is better as a
result then they come back and they want
to hear more from what what else should
i do because you're giving them honest
like you know objective
advice yeah i like the idea that his new
boss came out and and said hey we're
going to get back to telling news
stories and and how can you argue or
debate with that you know he said hey
we're a little bit too political want to
get back to our origin story which is
telling news which is the right thing
that's what you do you know cnn
really was
the top player for news for a long time
and when a story broke
you turned cnn on
and they destroyed that with chris cuomo
with don lemon and to a lesser extent
with brian stelter
they you know chris cuomo faking being
in coveted quarantine is one of the
biggest media scandals of of our
generations of our generation and it's
it's even even uh ben smith the new york
times called them out like this was
not something they could have just
pretended didn't happen everybody was
bringing up the fact that chris cuomo
pretended to be in quarantine and so
jeff sucker came in
and he turned cnn into a reality tv
he had a personal vendetta against
donald trump he hated the man and so he
nuked an entire legacy how amazing is
that
trump really
i don't know if he broke the minds of
these people
or if he like some kind of wizard pulled
it to the front and center for us to see
but these people's brains shattered when
when donald trump became president yeah
it was the news that i'd leaned on when
i was going through special operations
training special forces training uh when
the global war on terror was initiating
with the invasion of iraq and we were
already in afghanistan cnn is the
coverage i depended and leaned on for
accurate information which is crazy
because you know fighting the war and
then being away from home and not paying
attention to news to come home to that i
think in 2016 when i started paying
attention again to the news it's like
what's going on here it's completely
different world well i used to talk
about a couple years ago the cnn
challenge
the cnn challenge was to turn on cnn
and then
uh it was it was to be watching fox news
and then turn on cnn and the challenge
was can you find a time when they're not
talking about trump good luck
and so uh it used to be that i would i
would when i'm doing work i have cnn on
while i'm working and it's for if like
breaking news happens they'll have it
very quickly
and then eventually
uh
something happened with uh it was iran
it was protests or something like that
and they were talking about trump and
then i was like i'm seeing on twitter
something's going on and so i switched
to fox and there it is front center on
fox news protests erupting in iran and i
was like oh wow switch back to cnn and
then i was like what are they doing
there's like major international crisis
happening and they're talking about
trump trump's trump's not even relevant
to the news right now like he didn't do
anything they were just talking about
for the sake of talking about him and so
then something else happened later where
there was like a major flood i can't
remember exactly where and by this at
this point i'm only watching you know
america's newsroom on fox because they
actually were covering news and then i
thought to myself i bet if i turn on cnn
as trump click boom there it is so i
filmed it and i was like here's the
challenge guys like not a literal
challenge but i was like watch
that's all it was
they they they destroyed what legacy
they had and reliable sources to hear
that it's been on the air for nearly 30
years and then brian seltzer burned it
to the to the ground and they're
suffering i mean one of the reasons that
i think you probably seem licht like
chris licht who's who's licked i can't
say it i did pop culture this week and
learned i cannot read anyone's name
that's that's that's all i learned chris
l uh anyways he has taken over and part
of it is to get control of their massive
loss of their bleeding viewership and
their bleeding profits so it's there's
no way
there's no way for it to i mean one of
the things that i found interesting when
i was researching for the article was
that he has been monitoring who became
more
partisan under during the years that
donald trump was in office and he is it
looks like the reports are that he is
wanting to cut as many people who are
basically
too far gone there's no way to recover
the reputation of their show uh because
he thinks that it's more important to
bring them back to a moderate platform
and on our news i think that cnn's
reputation is so damaged with so many
americans that's an almost impossible
task but you know he's been given this
bleeding ship i mean he's got to try and
you know
bail out bail out i'm mixing metaphors
here
stop it from sinking somehow it's
bandaged the ship whatever he needs to
do
there's no way
there's no salvation but what will they
do sell the ip like sell the name to
disney or something or does disney
already sold it several times well it's
already under warner brothers right so
like it's already a conglomerate of a
conglomerate you know like it's already
mixed in somewhere i think eventually
uh someone else would maybe overtake
them as like the prime uh
left-leaning
news
outlet which is weird to even have to
say that like we should just have news
but of course we can't uh
what one of the things i found
interesting about seltzer is he
wrote this book about how fox news
thoughtful and trump and whatever else
and then he updated it after january 6
to be like see i told you guys even
worse than ever and now he is the first
one to go i mean he has really
positioned himself as the anti-trump
fact-checking media analyst and uh
his bias is too obvious what's he gonna
do what's he gonna go now is he well i
heard he's gonna come work here with the
chickens yeah yeah well you know i
that's i don't trust him with my
chickens he's gotta start a show like
his own show where he just uploads
videos interviews with him i don't know
he copies tim's format like i don't i
love to call them podcasts because
that's like an apple thing apple ipod is
where the podcast
word comes from and i'm tired of it i
don't trust i don't like apple
vodka podcast stealth should start his
own vodcast
people are saying he's going to start
his own podcast he's going to start
uploading uploading clips to youtube and
then his audience because it's
independent media is going to be very
anti-establishment and he's going to
drift further to the right and then
eventually have some flipping moment
where he's like i need to blow the
whistle on cnn jet fuel i feel like he
doesn't melt steel
i feel like he'd have to do the rounds
like you know how we have uh you know
conservatives who may fall out fall out
of like the establishment they do some
rounds on cnn they take positions there
and they're sort of like a punching bag
for a while i feel like he'd have to do
the opposite he'd have to like get some
i don't think any establishing
conservative media would take him but he
would need to sort of do the rounds and
be like well this is what i meant and
then have this whole redemption arc i
mean i think it would take a lot longer
than people think because he is so
publicly associated with being anti-maga
well cuomo he he founded the ccp did you
guys know that yeah he did the chris
cuomo project correct yeah
he literally called
chris
and no one was like no that's a bad idea
dude you should not do that i think
tucker carlson is an example that you
can
redeem yourself as because he was kind
of like a partisan hack in 2004-5 he
struck me as when he wore a bow tie i
talked about how great the war was i
mean at least i that's what i remember
him being kind of like a a war hawk and
then all of a sudden and it was jon
stewart somebody shocked him awake and
he realized yo what the hell is this
world well he talked he talks about it
on his show where he's like i used to
think this you know until i had a
conversation with this person and then
realized how wrong that was and it took
years for him to get back in people's
good graces but with honesty and
integrity and consistency you do i i'd
be willing to bet that if brian stelter
came out like a month and said i want to
blow the whistle on everything cnn was
doing the right would accept him in two
seconds and say yes by all means spill
all the beans publish everything and
we'll hear you out i just wonder if he
will though obviously i don't know him
personally but like i think it will be
very hard for him to
to flip like that i think he really sees
himself as this like doer of right
things progressive cause champion of you
know correct journalism i think it's
going to take longer i mean i think he's
going to have to hurt financially before
he's willing to give in
it's it's what's weird to see him do is
think on his own for in depth because he
looks like a it's like a talking head
right so he's reading the teleprompter
he probably wrote it deliberately and he
had this deliberate approach to
everything but to actually see him free
think through problems and through
challenges and politics that would
actually be entertaining to just listen
to see if he ends up like a tucker
carlson i think he's on the right side
of what we're talking about that's the
thing about stelter he does listen i i
see him in clips in time sometimes like
he's being humbled where he's like oh
what have i done oh god like there's
this ted koppel video i reposted jen
pearlman tweeted it out so i retweeted
it and ted koppel's like i mean this is
the reason why i don't remember exactly
talking about why cnn is failing why
why people don't believe you you talk
about trump every day if there's ten
thousand deaths in malaysia maybe it'll
get a mention but then it's just about
to trump trump trump and stelter's like
saying
just taking it you know i mean look he
he's not really true that's true yeah
what was he going to say be like well
womp yeah i've looked up cnn what it
stands for cable news network well as we
all know cable is done
so as is the c in cnn what's the new i
mean get rid of the name it doesn't make
sense anymore well i you know look with
uh liz cheney on tuesday being
uh
what's what's the right word trying to
be polite you're excised yeah say that
excised yes from the gop that's a it's a
good day and then today when uh i got a
message uh right before this happened
right before it was announced that
someone who has got sources hit me up
and said stelter's out here it comes and
then i was like i was like i need more
than this you can't just like dm me and
then i saw like a few minutes later the
breaking reports and i'm like oh man and
then i got i got uh uh word jim acosta
is going to be next so you know i look
forward to it um there's there's some
positive here let's jump to this next
story and get into the politics of of
the day we have this uh from timcast.com
trump accused of election meddling after
endorsing candidates in new york
democratic primary races
i'm sorry i love this man this is one of
the greatest trolls ever done
donald trump endorses lawyer dan goldman
who led the impeachment against him
saying lawyer dan goldman is running for
congress new york ten and it is my great
honor to strongly endorse him i do this
not because of the fact that he headed
up the impeachment committee and lost
but because he was honorable fair and
highly intelligent while it is well it
was my honor to beat him and beat him
badly
dan goldman has a wonderful future ahead
like i don't know how anyone sees that
anyone with any modicum of intelligence
and believes trump is literally
endorsing the guy when he's he's doing
like neg hits you know that is
it's like a backhanded compliment yeah
at these guys here's
he endorsed several other people but
here's the best part
you lean now who is a democrat so i i
looked her up she's a democrat assembly
member
running for new york ten
took the bait and said donald trump just
endorsed my multi-millionaire opponent
in case you need a reminder of what the
stakes are new york 10 choose your
fighter
she couldn't help it they can't help
themselves trump plays them like a
fiddle and now he's got them in fighting
over whether or not he actually supports
this guy this is what he has to do he
has the weight of the establishment
pushing against him right now and i've
been an advocate of like if someone's
coming at you and putting their full
force into you the best well one of the
best things you can do is move so that
you're not there anymore and that all
that pressure that donald trump is like
just goes into this nowhere land and end
up falling forward then you reappear and
then you're still back to you know who
you are the prophecy has been fulfilled
ladies and gentlemen from the babylon
bee ingenious move trump supports
impeachment forcing democrats to oppose
november 18th 2019 the beat does it
again wow the thing is his statement has
so much early 2016 energy to me like
there was a point in his presidency
where he really seemed to sort of get
lost i felt like maybe he didn't have uh
the correct support when he was already
in the white house but while he was
campaigning and you know throughout we
see we see it come go he really is just
this complete unpredictable force you
can't really tell what he's gonna do and
he doesn't want to
uh
adhere to any traditional standards so
it's why it's so funny like
this is this is very much a like true
spark of trump to me as like when he
first announced that he was coming to
president it reminds me of all of the
debates he did his like booing of
hillary clinton on stage like he doesn't
he doesn't behave as they would like him
to i'm sure goldman is like what do i do
do i release a statement saying no thank
you
this is so much of what trump does is
what i've been talking about when i say
like throw a pie figuratively like
people in power need to just need to to
set a tone need to call out the bs need
to make a point trump does this all the
time
it's it's it's quite incredible but uh
yeah i have to wonder where we go in
this country
as this is the current level of politics
that we have i mean they they take the
bait donald trump trolls the democrats
what do you think i think too like there
is a level of like yesterday i was
looking at this article it was eight of
the ten republicans who voted against
trump are out and
it's interesting because i think he's
trying to show the democrats that he has
influence within their party like not in
the way they're expecting he has more
influence in politics than anyone
predicts or is used to it's very unusual
to have a leader who can actually
bipartisanly reach across the aisles and
be like oh i it's not just the
republican primary side of influence i
can influence the democrats too he's not
even in office right now i love it can
you go back to the tweet the actual
tweet what what i find odd about the
original one the first one on the left
yeah is there's a dot dot
dot dot well it's because there's more
what i just mean i just mean like
everything about this four dots there's
four dots
everything about like i just look at it
and i i see i see psychological
operations campaign it's like a psyop
right it's like exactly what you do when
you want to win hearts and minds and
if it's a real endorsement or if it's
not a real endorsement what what we
realize now is that uh everybody's
talking about it yep and that's what you
need when you're trying to campaign
early on we're three years out two and a
half two and some change out and we'll
start filling the effects of that like
tomorrow
we're filling it today and so this is
only going to get more extreme and and
more difficult but how much of this is
donald trump sitting down with a group
of like tacticians being like we need to
craft the perfect message or it's him
lounging in a chair watching tucker
cross and being like anders is a guy and
he like grabs a thing of cheetos and
then i feel it's like both of those
i think he's good on a whim but i also
think like deliberately
uh people people forget he's a very
crafty business person and being in
business myself for a short period of
time i understand the tactics even
tactics that i've brought across the
military aisle in planning and strategy
he is using all of these tactics to bear
and i think he's unpredictable he would
be unconventional or irregular in his
warfare approach while the rest of the
establishment uh that you're draining
that he's training is very conventional
i'm just thinking about you know they
call him a fascist they claim he's like
worse than hitler could you imagine if
donald trump like ever did become a
dictator and then history is talking
about how he rose to power and it's like
well he called rozier dental fat pig and
then he made a tweet endorsing his
opponents
it's just like wow
you know the history repeats itself
history rhymes but i think we're getting
something fresh with donald trump to a
certain degree i gotta ask is this the
4d chess we were promised that's kind of
what it looks like to me yeah i like to
think when you hate if you hate somebody
that they are controlling you
if you have a mo so people that he's
done that he i mean he's taking control
of people's minds whether yeah whether
they like him or not well especially the
ones that hate
yeah yeah that's a way that's a form of
4d chess
i'm just reading the end of this like
winning against him made me realize so
just very talented i am amazing okay let
me read it let me read it so i read the
first part he goes on to say he will be
very compassionate and compromising to
those within the within the republican
party and will do everything possible to
make sure they have a fair chance at
winning against the radical left
democrats who he knows are destroying
our country i would like to thank dan
for fighting so hard for america and for
working so tirelessly to stop quote
trump unquote he was not easy to beat
but winning against him made me realize
just how very talented i am most don't
read the second one though i'm so sorry
this just like gets better and better
that's great i hope one person said to
him like oh be hilarious if you endorse
the demo like democrat and then he's
like i'm done do it right now he's like
he's like sitting in like his friend's
basement they're playing pool with the
game on and they're like dude dude you
should endorse the democrats like i'm
totally gonna do it it would make him
freak out and they're like he's like
okay that's what i love
so he super chatted him i was like you
won't do it he was like oh yes i will
yeah i think maybe he has realized that
conventional tactics are not the way you
win against the liberal economic order
right now because they're just
conventionally using brute force you
know with the fbi raid on the house and
things like that so now he's taking an
unconventional i think
we saw the democrats funding republican
messaging
and the idea was that it was going to
hurt trump to do this i think he was
like okay i'll play the game you like
you want to play that game yeah you so
so think the democrats are like trump
endorsed these guys so let's prop them
up then in the general they'll lose so
trump says okay i'll endorse your guys
instead
and does
that's what i mean i think he they
underestimate how much influence he has
over everyone like we see it as like oh
it's just just those right people those
conservatives the maga base but it's
really not like trump is an institution
in and of himself and i think
you know he is sort of reviving the same
kind of disruptive energy that made him
stand out initially which made people
cover him when he was running in 2016
because they were like what is he doing
well he put his name in quotes too which
is nice because it shows that he's not
like he was against me he sees that he's
against the idea of what trump might be
yeah but someone said someone was steve
steve bannon's mullet responded to you
lynn
saying that's just weird why would he
endorse goldman and she said he said it
out loud to stop the left
i do not believe i'm sorry i can't
believe that this uh you lin woman i've
proposing that right
actually believes it's a real
endorsement maybe she doesn't know
do you think she seriously thinks
maybe she's playing her own side but i
don't buy into it i think she literally
probably believes that it was an
endorsement maybe she's betting off
headlines like enough people are going
to see trump endorses goldman she's like
they aren't going to look into it i'm
going to be able to yeah but that would
mean that she knows she's lying to her
potential constituents she's possible
right is she is she lying for votes or
is she just really that dumb i'm going
with lying for votes for 500.
neither one seems like a good look you
know yeah my guess is ignorant that she
doesn't know that was the guy that tried
to impeach no he wrote that he headed
the impeachment committee it's in the
endorsement damn that i was wrong but
we're also i mean here here's the credit
to trump that's due that a lot of people
don't talk about this is a tactician
that killed isis like this dude like we
forget about isis and all the problems
that it was taking over the world we
were about to go to world war ten
he did that on his own accord as a
commander-in-chief and nobody talks
about like they ragged on him for it
they did they write him they said
austere scholar
how did he do it
well he i think he used i mean he used a
lot of different tactics but he used
special operations but it wasn't
advertised as a war so it wasn't
campaigning with media outlets that were
telling all the information it was a
closed compartmentalized operation that
was very deliberate using ranger
battalion using the best special special
mission units in the world
and crushed those guys and if it wasn't
for that i mean the things that we saw
on the tv when isis and their propaganda
was affecting the world
everybody was like in fear you saw
little kids running around with guns
killing innocent people from propaganda
videos from isis that was a thing like
we lived in that time and all of a
sudden we woke up one day like covet and
it didn't exist and it's because of
those tactics that he brought to bear so
i say that because he's a he's
deeply seated in strategy and
understanding tactics on all levels and
i think this is an easy psyops campaign
for him
yeah is is psy up the right word is a
politician him trying to garner a favor
in votes is it just
well i guess sayop is the right thing to
call it it's not it's not propaganda you
can call perhaps black propaganda but
it's not really right yeah psychological
operations would be like
the intent
to twist things around from the get-go
the onset and whether it was like a
haphazard like oh i think i'm just going
to do this and blast it out or hey let's
meet about this either way it had the
same same effect you're familiar with
the concept of black propaganda yeah for
sure could you explain that yeah i mean
there's well propaganda across the board
in the psychological campaign has
many outlets i'm not a psychological
expert but psychological operations is
part of what special operations does and
and every side of the coin
uh whether it's influencing bad guys to
target bad guys which i've done in the
military um or it's twisting hearts and
minds for for egregious reasons
um it basically is to control the
battlefield with with people's emotions
and behaviors in mind so if you could
affect people's emotions if you could
affect people's i mean i just did this
for a a tv show that we're doing
and uh we we were talking about our
asian very superior um genetics on
before we can't say that before the
podcast that's a joke so he's quarter
korean i didn't know that but um i'm
half korean technically twenty percent
some five percent japanese yeah i'm 13
japanese because that whole invasion
thing you know yeah i know you know
raping and pillaging that stuff that bad
stuff
so uh we did a piece on um vietnam and
there was a psychological campaign that
was them taking um pieces of equipment
audio tape equipment recording uh
vietnamese actors and actresses
getting that the information um and and
in this case it was their culture where
they believed in ghosts
and they went out into the field and
they played these voices of ghost
telling the enemy you need to go home
playing the ghost of a daughter this is
vietnam or this is vietnam yeah i i
heard about this story
before yeah wandering soul backfired it
it backfired because the people in
placing it were so freaked out
that they started disaffecting off the
battlefield and you know they it was
effective and they they did a uh
they used a uh tiger a a a roar from a
tiger and they had a 150 vietnamese nor
in this case north vietnamese disaffect
the communists disaffected and left
their guns in place and and evaded they
did the same thing with the ghost thing
but it backfired because both sides in
the culture just like a religious or
ideological ideological uh campaign it
affects both sides it's crazy the
recordings were wailing voices yes
saying i should have never so in their
culture they believe that if you're not
properly buried yeah you're doomed to
wander around aimlessly wandering soul
yep yeah so
these these voices are heard in the
forest saying i should run while you
still can leave before it's too late or
you'll be trapped here like i am there's
chills now it's like
little girl voices from these little
girls that were saying daddy please
please please don't go home go home and
they were like in this the middle of the
night triple chan uh canopy jungle and
you're like what is that and you hear it
and dude dude that would work that would
work on anyone
is it because the the allied troops
didn't know that it was happening so
they thought it was real where did they
know and they were still free
they knew but they didn't know most
psychological campaigns like this are
classified right this was declassified
uh years later they have a time stamp on
it but when they were in placing it and
they played it they thought i assumed
they thought that this was actually
recordings of ghost and they were just
emplacing it and somehow the americans
got a hold of it but they were using
indigenous forces they were using the
local nationals to put the stuff in so
they wouldn't be part of the operation
actually but i think there is there's
just no way for everyone to know it was
an operation so if you have you know 10
local vietnamese helping you but there's
a hundred within a few miles who end up
hearing it they start spreading the word
farmers the local civilian populists
started hearing it as well and they were
leaving everything so even the support
that potentially the good guys were
depending on everybody was abandoning i
kind of feel like they should have
rolled with it because it prevented
death
you know
yeah i mean hey let's end the war by
just freaking everybody out making them
put their guns down yeah double-edged
sword of psychological games so that's
the question like if both sides were
laying down arms and fleeing isn't that
like a better option than
but the united states wanted our guys to
go with guns and start taking control so
60 plus thousand americans paid for
their lives for that war what a reckless
war oh it's horrific yeah annihilated
well
let me ask you a question um
when it came to afghanistan
uh i've never been a fan of it you know
i grew up with uh the invasion and
nothing seemed to make sense and the
media lied about so much it was used to
justify so much awful stuff when uh when
joe biden surrendered and then
in my opinion intentionally
just destroyed our standing in
afghanistan giving a bagram
a lot of people mentioned you know i was
like we shouldn't have been there in the
first place i think biden did it wrong
we got a few super chats where they said
should the u.s have stayed in korea
should they have been involved there and
i thought that was an interesting
question because i've been to seoul and
i think it's absolutely amazing and it
would not be there if the us did not
intervene it would be
the entirety of the peninsula would be
under a communist boot i'm curious as to
your thoughts on u.s intervention you
know vietnam was was senseless
it was it was crushing we lied gulf of
tonkin to get involved but what are your
thoughts on on the korean war yeah it's
a good question i i think you know when
you look at even japan because you know
the korean war was because of the
japanese basically we're fighting over
the dominance of that land from the
japanese and we're saying hey you know
these guys owned it who owns it we're
going to fight for it and we wanted to
fight in china and japan for it and you
know the korean war spanned from 1950 to
1953. my my dad stationed on the
demilitarized zone in korea met my
beautiful mother in korea as a 19 he was
a 20 something year old soldier she was
a 19 year old
local gal the strongest economies in the
world were japan and korea why are they
the strongest economies because of the
the stable environment we were able to
set with the security provided the
problem with afghanistan is we didn't
provide that security so when you look
at where we are even in iraq where we we
maintain a signature there when you pull
the plug on off support which is what we
did i mean my buddy tim kennedy and a
group of
of merry men
volunteered with save our allies with
with uh chad robichaun the mighty oaks
foundation and went in and extracted
thousands of american civilians
and afghans that worked with us
i did two rotations of combat to
afghanistan and it's disgusting how we
pulled the plug on those men just like
we did in vietnam we did the same exact
thing we don't learn the histories
or the history of of failure which we
did in the military on both sides and it
was it was a problem it was a huge
problem i've heard that uh we could have
succeeded in vietnam i don't i don't i'm
not a history buff or any of this stuff
but i was watching some documentary
talking about when the u.s decided to
pull out and that there were there were
moves they could have made oh ho chi
minh was trained by the office of
strategic service he was trained by the
cia
originally and basically disaffect we we
disaffected him because we didn't want
an alliance between him and the french
and and we let him do his thing which
meant going to war
with ho chi minh and so 1958 to 1975
that entire span of war costs a lot of
american lives because we didn't have
the proper strategy and you know what it
is i think it has a lot to do with
turnover
the government and the military has a
high turnover rate where you might
implement a strategy and even individual
tactics on the battlefield you'll do
your time the next guy comes in and goes
well i need to make my impact on the
world well i need to have an officer
evaluation report that says that i did
something epic and we continue this
momentum until the end of afghanistan
we're like what the hell are we doing
here i've lost i lost buddies of mine at
the tail end of afghanistan and at that
point i said to myself even early on in
afghanistan when i was there was like
this is for a just reason and then i was
like what the hell are we doing here why
did we lose that guy amazing american
why do we do why do we do that well
that's that's the thing people talk
about how you know the us has maintained
a military presence in south korea
maintaining its security and i'm like
germany too yeah it might be 40 years in
germany the korea thing's a little
different though there's an act of war
yeah you've got you've got outright
communists you've got people in north
korea starving they're they're they're
in an actual cult reality where they
believe in same things and then you have
south korea i actually got to interview
this group of new zealanders
who they like to ride their motorcycles
on on famous uh
i guess journeys so they did the silk
road right they were all they did they
went around i think like south america
along the coasts and then one thing they
really wanted to do was go from north
korea to south korea and they wondered
if it was possible well new zealand is
like
no one's got a problem with new zealand
yeah right so when they reached out
this this might come to surprise people
it was actually north korea that wanted
it to happen
north korea said please do this trip
because
it's a good pr for us south korea didn't
want it to happen because it was good pr
for north korea they eventually figured
out how to do it how to how to negotiate
it and i think the story was it's been a
decade since i interviewed them it was
back when i was advice was that they
were told by the americans and the south
koreans like
don't don't come and then they came
anyway and said look we're going to be
at the dmz you better accept us and they
were like uh what do we do and here's
the amazing thing they said when they
entered north korea they had a
government
escort and they they drove through these
towns and everyone would wave to them
everybody knew who they were that they
were coming that the government made
sure everybody was like they're going to
come we're going to bring them through
everyone's going to stand here at this
time and wave and it's like kind of
freaky story when they made it to the
dmz and crossed over there was no way to
get motorcycles through this place they
said once they came on the other side
they were escorted by the press
that was the difference between north
and south korea the government mandating
it and the free press rushing there by
choice to try and cover it yeah so i
bring that up because
i wonder if we we maintained that uh if
we had a universal attitude towards
never intervening in anything ever would
south korea be a hellish dictatorship
and is it is it worth it i mean i look
my my family left before and it was
partly because of rising tensions my my
grandparents family that's my
understanding i could be wrong um so i'd
still be here but i'm i'm just i'm
curious as to your thoughts in that in
that regard i mean if you understand if
we were able to maintain a presence in
afghanistan could it have turned out to
be something like seoul where yeah i
think the number one priority for any
country to gain its sovereignty back if
it you know if you look at old pictures
from the 70s and 80s of afghanistan it
was a very modern society i mean in
kabul
and kandahar there's like convertibles
and women were wearing their hair down
it wasn't this radical thing that we
look at now with sharia law in
afghanistan so
the presence alone of security is what
would have maintained a jumping point
for us to conduct
those supported counterterrorism
operations to suppress all of the things
all the guys that wanted to come in we
they just dropped the bomb on zarahiri
on his balcony yeah and supported by the
taliban and uh
it was called or whatever yeah and it's
like that was the win because he was he
was osama bin laden's 2yc he was a
second in charge i sat on checkpoints in
2004 and 2005 trying to capture this guy
and he was we everybody assumed he was
dead he shows up all of a sudden because
he's celebrating his freedom
supported by the taliban and it's like
what are we doing like the most bizarre
thing that i heard when all this was
going down and tim and chad were
activating they had they had messaged me
about it
nick all these guys amazing men
when i heard
that we had outer containment on that
airfield provided by the taliban
i was like
what what did a general on tv just say
outer containment was being provided by
the taliban did he say that did he say
our enemy is literally providing
security on the outer containment oh
what happened a few days after that oh a
an ied went off and killed 13 americans
wow it's insane like it all you we
needed is to maintain the airfields the
bases and then that would be enough to
suppress the terrorism
ian says it every single time that biden
surrendered it completely yeah yeah
completely surrendered it and it it
gives me chills in a bad way because
we had all the opportunity there and i i
i got one of my guys out with saber
allies who helped me so thank you so
much sabra allies who worked with me and
american forces for decades and we were
willing to abandon him his brother who
worked for us was killed and executed by
the taliban we're willing to commit
their entire lives
um and to wasteland knowing that they
helped us because we completely pulled
the plug with no excuses now they're the
most capable fighting force in the world
as a terrorist organization
mostly because we we did that i mean
look night vision is the scary thing for
operators going into warfare right you
do a deliberate operation direct action
hit you go in there with confidence
knowing hey these guys can't see us we
own the night is the idea
now they have thermal
infrared
flare systems on pods to be able to
track all of that and that's scary for
uh
for any
friendly force that's going into harm's
way
you know part of me felt like it was
punishment for the for the
anti-interventionists for the trump
supporters because donald trump sets
this time frame to exit afghanistan and
then joe biden just
i i assume it was intentionally screwed
the whole thing up some speculation was
that by screwing up so bad it would
create a justification for a return
instead of just maintaining a security
presence or at least
when bagram was being abandoned give a
phone call to the security forces like
hey you might want to go to the the air
air force or the air air base right now
instead looters showed up yeah that that
i cannot imagine was an accident that
you abandoned in the middle of the night
without telling your partners in the
security forces in the country it fell
apart so fast
i just it seems deliberate yeah one of
the things that is a problem that
happened because i've i've planned
non-combatant evacuations for mali for
libya i spent a year in libya working
with the the agency but also working for
the military
when you do a non-combatant evacuation
order
you go through a deliberate planning
process what was what happened was the
state department a foreign service
agency was giving given the ball on
running that plan
the state department can't plan a
retirement party overseas let alone a
deliberate operation to evacuate
innocent people so the military's
specialty is that special operations
command
socom has the authority in combatant
command theaters which includes
afghanistan to do these kind of
operations and they they train for it i
train for it we do it for a living and
they handed the state department said
you lead it you do it and they didn't do
anything right it's one of the reasons
why they failed they handed it is it
biden was it biden that handed it to the
state department yeah 100 i mean yeah he
gave it to this the secretary of state
who ran the ball and then they dropped
the ball all over the the country i'm
with tim i feel like it's like his way
of intentionality like saying oh trump
you want to pull out on this day well
here this is what happens when you rush
it donald trump it's it's not just that
it's that there's there's a
long-standing you know international
policy that
the agency of the united states had
right that they had a plan in place of
like how we're handling things and trump
disrupted the whole thing and it kind of
felt like uh like a sour grapes almost
like you came in and you screwed up what
we were doing so there you go that's
what you get yeah that's that's your
afghanistan trump biden set this
september 11th deadline name it was
clear that he was trying to present
himself as like he pushed the deadline
for yeah he did temper
so i you know i kind of wonder you know
um
there there's
we saw that viral video i think it was
um was it the taliban who got that truck
from detroit with the guy's phone number
on it yeah and
so a lot of people have talked about
whether or not the us wanted isis to
exist because under obama they flourish
and it was convenient because syria was
an enemy of the united states was
obstructing our plans with the qatar
turkey pipeline syria i'm sorry isis
comes into syria and then starts
destabilizing it trump gets in crushes
isis like that so i have to wonder if
part of it is
the united states was well aware of the
problems in the middle east but were
were accepting it as a benefit to the
united states in the long run trump
ending that pissed him off maybe they
want to destabilize the region and so
this is why they turn over weapons and
make the taliban as powerful as they are
now yeah it seems very deliberate
and very intentional because you can't
imagine that i can't imagine that none
of the generals including general miller
who is a freaking hero in my mind who
ran afghanistan who left prior to the
departure of them pulling the plug that
none of those generals came to the the
table and said listen what you're
planning what you're talking about is is
reckless and as soon as we saw
different regions of the taliban taking
out these places as it closed in on
kandahar and kabul we should have
changed tactics but we didn't and i've
seen that from the state department i
saw it in libya i saw it in pakistan the
state department is very risk adverse
there's always a battle between the
intelligence community department of
defense and the state department because
the state department the consulate
they're trying to maintain diplomatic
relations but their priority is
supporting the president of the united
states dod's priority is supporting the
national security of the country so it's
like these things go to head and then
the losers are the afghan people we you
know we talk a lot about maybe there was
intentional maybe there are reasons
behind it i want to jump to this next
story which suggests
everything you've heard about the
problems trump faced may actually be a
result of trump derangement syndrome in
this tweet jackpot posted a video from
the trigonometry podcast shout out guys
from the trigonometry
sam harris quote hunter biden literally
could have had the corpses of children
in his basement i would not have cared
this is going viral like crazy in since
this morning 3.3 million views sam
harris basically says
that the the uh
what he calls a left-wing conspiracy to
suppress information
to try and stop trump from winning the
presidency was acceptable and good it
was warranted and constantine's like i i
have to stop you you're saying you're
okay
with this manipulation to prevent
someone from winning a democratic
election and sam harris is like yup oh
he actually tracks back and says no no
no i i i i didn't you know i stutters a
lot of time let's play it let's play
let me make sure i always have the audio
set to the wrong center yeah
all right here we go point hunter bind
literally could have had had
the corpses of children in his basement
i would not have cared right it's like
it's there's nothing first of all it's
hunter biden right it's not it's like
it's not joe biden but
even if joe like even whatever scope of
joe biden's corruption is like if you if
we could just go down that rabbit hole
endlessly and and
understand that he's getting kickbacks
from hunter biden's deals in ukraine or
whatever else right or china
it is
infinitesimal
compared to the corruption we know trump
is involved in it's like it's like it's
like a firefly to the sun right i mean
like there's just it doesn't even it
doesn't even stack up against trump
university let me pause you right there
sam
let me just say something right now
trump university
trump university so so trump launched
university and may have
his argument defrauded a a a handful of
people into giving up some cash and he's
comparing that to hunter biden on the
board of barisma joe biden's quid pro
quo the war that has erupted and is
spreading across the country the people
who have died and lost their cities joe
biden sending billions of dollars to the
ukrainians so when you're saying like
maybe he's getting kickbacks you know i
don't know who cares what's in the
laptop
it is entirely possible that joe biden's
hunter entanglements are what's
exacerbating this conflict and you think
trump university is so much worse this
is the point i'm trying to get to
trump derangement syndrome is so
intense in these people's minds
what sam is saying makes literally no
sense if trump really is the con man
they think he is he's conned some
american people out of their money some
property owners and sure that's bad but
joe biden is conning the entirety of the
country to the world and putting us in a
very very precarious and dangerous place
with his inability to do his job and if
hunter biden really is involved in say
chinese private equity deals our
security is compromised well beyond
trump ripping off some fat woman who
bought a university ticket
i'm sorry man sam harris is this stuff
this stuff lights me up let's play more
right trump university as a story
is worse than anything that could be in
in hunter biden's laptop insane right
what no that's not it doesn't answer the
people who say there's there's images of
hunter biden in the buff with family
members young miners yeah that have been
released from this
there there is he shares his bank
account his phone number with his dad
according to some reports he calls his
dad a pedo and trump university is worse
than anything let's play more to not
have looked at the laptop in a timely
way and to have shut down the you know
the new york post's twitter account like
that that's just a conspiracy left-wing
conspiracy to deny the presidency to
donald trump absolutely it was
absolutely right but i think it was
warranted right and and again it's a
coin toss as to whether or not i'm sorry
that particular piece i'm really sorry i
was the one that said we should move on
but you've just said something i really
struggled with that which is
no no [ __ ] the kids in the basement i'm
interested in democracy you're saying
you are content
with the left-wing conspiracy to prevent
somebody being democratically re-elected
as president well no i i'm conte well so
it's but the thing is it's just not
left-wing right so liz cheney is not
left-wing right oh man liz cheney is
doing everything in her policy to
prevent somebody from getting democrats
it's not like no but there's nothing
conspiracy it's not it was a conspiracy
out in the open it does but it doesn't
matter if it was it doesn't matter what
parts conspiracy what parts out in the
open i mean i think it's like
if people get together and talk and talk
about what should we do about this
phenomenon you know if it's like if
there was an asteroid hurtling toward
earth
and and we got in a room together with
all of our friends and had a
conversation about what we could do to
deflect its course right
is that a conspiracy you know like
someone
like that last 20 seconds is absolutely
flubber like he's not even making any
sense together he said it was a
left-wing conspiracy to make sure that
donald trump didn't get democratically
elected and he was fine with it that's
what he said and then he walked it back
and said no it wasn't a conspiracy and
it wasn't left-wing like he just said it
he just said it sam this is an this is
an example of intelligence without
wisdom the guy
goes on these logical tirades which have
no emotional
integrity no no like the the the saying
is
intelligence is knowing that a tomato is
a fruit wisdom is knowing not to put in
a fruit salad and i think
right on from from ian's it's the right
point sam harris is an intelligent guy
but he's he's it's it's
it's like it's a lack of emotional
control to say something as insane
wrong
on moral and factual points is just like
this is the danger i mean sam harris is
a very high profile guy with a very
large audience and he is a guy who goes
out and talks about the zealotry of
religious groups and how dangerous it is
and then look at what he says there's no
rhyme or reason to anything he was just
saying other than he's an authoritarian
who would use
by any means necessary powers to crush
people he doesn't like i think what
strikes him the most is his last
metaphor if there was an asteroid coming
to earth and we made a plan to stop it
that would be okay right that's not a
conspiracy like he is so convinced that
what's happening with trump is just this
uncontrollable unpredictable force
he can't accept the fact that people
think differently than he does and they
want trump to be in office that they
don't agree with his perspective and
therefore he it's
the whole thing he said was mishmash
nonsense like like you mentioned like
the last 20 seconds flubber walking back
changing what he's saying he's eats this
is
constantine
the trigonometry guys
they have values they have principles
they're they're in inquisitive they're
trying to understand things and this was
brilliant
this is what real journalism is this is
not we don't get this from brian seltzer
we don't get this from cnn this is him
just literally saying okay you've made
your point
this is my question to you and then he
sends sam harris into a into a spiral of
nonsense yeah i mean what they think
constantly just the best is he has a
specific thesis he's trying to answer
which is like what can you do to defend
democracy where do you draw the lines
between what is acceptable and what is
not and
i don't think sam harris has the moral
compass to say
like oh yes i respect how democracy
works like for him it doesn't matter but
but what's what do you think is causing
this trump derangement syndrome like
look i understand trump says mean things
and you might be like he lacks decorum
but to this degree
like
i think a lot of it has to do with
you know you like he said
this dude's very intelligent i mean he's
super intelligent i i appreciated him up
until you posted this on your twitter
feed and was like are you kidding me
that's crazy because it it seems very
deranged
but i think a lot of that is caused by
him living in an echo chamber he lives
in a bubble in an echo chamber he's used
to hearing the same people talk about
the same things
and just as he refers to the asteroid
hitting the earth like that's what he's
correlating his argument to like the
worst case scenario in the world
you're comparing it to that what i what
i think is fascinating like you
mentioned
is these two guys are actually being
journalists like and this is surprising
because it's like what is this thing
called like you know
objective reasoning on through
journalism like they're actually having
a conversation and he's willing to
confront sam harris on this and catches
sam harris off guard which i love
because like you said as soon as he
catches them off guard he starts going
down a a drain and he knows he's
circling the drain he's probably killing
time he's looking at the clock he's like
oh crap i don't know what to say you
know you know what this is
sam said the quiet part loud not not
realizing that he would be challenged
and that i think
what sam said is what he truly believes
in his heart of hearts yes but
that is not something you can say
right now when you're trying to maintain
this you know principal position of
opposing authoritarianism no he is an
outright authoritarian as so many of
these anti-trump people are what's the
what's the what's the big it's crazy
i see these people on facebook saying
you know trump's a fascist fire
authoritarian and so and they're saying
the same thing about ron desantis and
i'm like what have they done
trump wouldn't even bring in the
military to stop the rioting we watched
the writing go on all over the country
and trump said well i can't
man i'm sure a lot of people wished he
was more fascist and would have would
have stopped this rioting he didn't do
it
then you get antifa going around and
where is that accountability they get
propped up by the media and the
corporations they get defended they get
defended by cnn there's there's a
compilation daily why put out chris
cuomo is like the problem is not you
know the writers the problem is what
made your fellow man have to go out and
riot or something like that and it's
like no no dude
these people are going around and
there's no rhyme or reason to what
they're destroying
this is exactly it
sam there there was a viral tweet where
a guy was in beverly hills and he was
cheering on the riots and he was like
yeah riot woo
and then later on he tweets like why are
you coming to beverly hills stop don't
come here go downtown no no what are you
doing
yeah they love it when they're watching
these people destroy other people's
lives
but when it turns to them
jimmy dore i think i think i have a
tweet from jimmy dora
jimmy dore tweeted quote i'm for
censorship if it helps my side
politically i mean i just can't see a
downside to thinking like this because i
don't read history and i'm super smarter
than you
i see i'm stuttering like sam he he he
didn't didn't he didn't write say
sense like that's the only way to stop
the asteroid because that's what they
equate trump to i think that he
isn't
used to being pushed back i think maybe
he would have like i i don't know if
this happens on the show that often but
i think there are people who go on and
expect
to be interviewed in a very positive
sort of softball way they expect people
to be like oh yeah i get what you're
saying that makes sense thank you so
much for being here and i really you
know i applaud constantine for being
like we have to return to the thesis
which is that you would be willing
to
like circumvent democracy yeah
let's uh let's get to the meet potatoes
here on this story though civil war oh
yeah right what's the possibility we
have this from project veritas dhs
whistleblower leaks new joint
intelligence bulletin on domestic
violent extremists set in wake of
mar-a-lago raid i mean this is crazy
stuff here dves
information contained in this
intelligent bulletin is for official use
only blah blah blah project veritas
released a leaked document today from
within the department of homeland
security which shows how federal
agencies are reacting to a recent raid
of trump's florida home
considering the trump derangement
syndrome of people like sam harris and
then we learn about people in the
federal government who are saying things
like this my concern is that
sam harris's level of derangement exists
within the dhs
and this is going to make things
dangerous so i know this is the report
that uh that that smeared you do you
want to give us a breakdown of what what
happened yeah so project veritas drops
and leaks this document which is sent to
like all special agents right it's like
uh
think about it like a memorandum or an
updated pamphlet to educate your special
agents in the field it's not supposed to
be disseminated outside of the
institution outside of their portal so
they get this and it's an educational
piece to inform like what are the new
trends and this one says both militia
and domestic violent extremists which
they use both those terms and then it
has a whole bunch of different pictures
of different organizations
including
my organization american contingency
which is is pretty crazy i again i
started american contingency with this
idea of bringing community and people
together that idea stemmed from
a a seattle experience where if you
remember uh
what is the the name of the uh town it
was uh the fake little town that in
seattle they stood up chats
jazz yeah so it's supposed to be a a
utopian
universe for everybody to flourish and
then it turned quickly into a socialist
safe haven because they had uh
armed uh guards they had checkpoints
checking ids and and it didn't work out
for anybody so they killed people yeah
and when that happened they started
migrating and then peaceful protests
turned into violent extreme protests
and for the first time it came out that
people who were law-abiding citizens
said we need help from the police now my
company phil craft survival we teach
this idea you are your own first
response because whether it's breaking
your leg in the middle of a utv trail
a natural disaster man-made disaster
you're going to be the first on scene
know how to treat injury know how to
respond know how to do something so
that's our educational platform well
when they didn't respond because they
the politicians told the police do not
respond because the political climate
won't support this don't respond they
put law-abiding citizens in harm's way
and i said we're going to do something
about it amcon american contingency now
what happened because i talked to
veritas i talked to these guys
what happened is
a special agent within the fbi
saw that we started this militia
organization which we are listed as a
militia
and this organization which they labeled
has a low
history of violence they called they
said my organization has a low history
bound we have zero history of violence
on january 6 people actually asked me in
the organization we're talking a hundred
thousand people they asked me mike what
are we gonna do here i said it's easy
we're gonna i'll release a statement and
i'll give you the guidance and
and i i hated even being that but i was
i knew i represented as a as a speaking
head kind of the guidance for the
organization i said listen group leaders
well we're not going to do anything it's
a protest that potentially could be
dangerous what we are going to do is
report all of the things that would
benefit people on the outskirts of this
protest so we can give them force
protection measures and intelligence and
information so they could protect
themselves so we could say hey the crowd
is moving into x neighborhood be sure
that you're aware lock your doors
protect your family that was the number
one objective
to be called a violent
uh militia and extremists by both the
public which is not surprising who's
miseducated and misinformed but then by
the government on top of that
in the same week by the way
the government called us a militia
violent extreme group
the leftists called me a white
nationalist and a racist which is
fascinating because i have black mexican
korean white in my same family you're
you're literally a mixed race person
mixed-race person and then the far right
call me a bootlicker because i reported
that i even cooperated with the fbi um
during this time period not during
january 6 but we had a guy who who said
he was going to shoot up some innocent
people i am a law-abiding citizen you
come into my public forum in my business
in my group and say you're going to
shoot and harm people i am going to
report you to local authorities that
same person took a picture of a special
agent's business card i don't know how
he got it but he took a picture of it
and posted it on our form which was on
locals we originally were on locals in
fact dave rubin started locals with the
idea of getting behind a paywall
protected from these social media sites
that were canceling and deleting people
except we were bit the biggest platform
on locals we were bigger than david
you're not on locals anymore we we once
they sold
things started changing in the algorithm
and we it was too much for us to
moderate because on locals you have to
self-monitoring so
i started seeing the woes of eating
social media i'm like how do you how do
you keep this this talk and the
negativity down so we migrated to our
own server on americancontingency.com
so all this happens in the same week and
i'm like
i feel like i'm living in middle earth i
feel like i'm a moderate and i'm like
this is what happens when you decide
that you just want to go to work you
want to feed your family you want to
serve the country and you want to live
in freedom for the rest of your days you
become the enemy of everybody on the
fringes and that's exactly what we are
but the fringes are almost everybody
these days it seems that way here's what
i say i say like like evan hafer who
owns black rifle coffee a good friend of
mine me and him have the same social
political views on a lot of things in
life because we fought war for decades
we come back from that war and
experience and go i don't want civil war
people are like mike's taking us to war
no my glover's not taking you anywhere
i've experienced enough of that you
don't want any of that i've been to
africa to the middle east you don't want
any of that world and so there is a big
pull of this
i think it's what it's ultimately the
people that are listening to you because
you're not on the fringes you're
actually just
logical
reasonable and you're talking about this
fringe ideology that's affecting
everybody and you just want to with the
truth bomb you just want to live
somewhere in between but the the thing i
bring up i mean
look man
you've got the fbi right on donald trump
they accuse him of being a fascist he's
certainly none of these things they've
lied about him relentlessly they've just
made all the stuff up it's becoming
impossible to be left alone and you know
my thing is
what i will say
they're going after alex jones with
everything they have because of his
influence
and they're going after donald trump
because of his influence because they
know they can't stop him this november i
mean look we just liz cheney's gone
carrie lake just won brian stelter is
out these are these are tremendous
cultural shifts in a very positive
direction which is all really good news
i'm hoping that if we maintain this
trajectory then we avoid
any kind of real conflict
but when you look at the lengths that
the machine has gone even smearing you
it's like bro you're the guy who's
saying quite literally please let me
just raise my family and be left alone
and they're not letting you they're
they're they're putting this this bolt
in out they're coming you know smearing
and insulting i i worry this is going to
escalate
to something you know
substantially worse right i talk about
civil war quite a bit we we will be
here's what i here's the prediction from
mike glover who runs field craft
survival and and does this for a living
looking at preparedness looking at
threats
um it's my academic experience it's also
my counterterrorism counterintelligence
experience
on
during the election cycle
we will see
a massive disruption and on election
night prior and after you will see
a a
what feels like civil war and heavily in
the next few months in the next few
years okay because we're going to have a
lead up all the social media platforms
are going to start getting leverage the
the troll farms from china russia north
korea's influence will start affecting
us like it did with blm and antifa and
the election cycle and what you're going
to see up is a lead up attention
and and and what you're seeing is
politician
irresponsibly weaponizing government
agencies and people
and what you're going to see and
especially in heavy populated areas
is what looks like a civil war you're
going to see imagine this scenario you
have antifa and blm who comes out like
they did and they start burning down the
streets except now you're going to have
the right fringe who's going to come out
and go we won't accept this it's not
just that during the summer of love
locals just a political people were seen
standing on their street corners with
rifles 100 so so then you have this this
imbalance where you have
leftist extremists right-wing extremists
and then the people in the middle just
defending what they own their families
their friends their communities and then
all of these things are happening and
then it starts bleeding into the
outskirts it starts affecting everybody
but what happens when
the law enforcement officers are caught
in the middle
now are they not supposed to defend
their lives they're in the middle of an
active gunfight so take the written
house situation and amplify that in a
full skirmish where the battlefield are
the streets of densely populated areas
like chicago where you come from so uh
you've seen beaver vendetta yes yeah i
wanna just
just think of that scene at the end
where the guy says eventually someone
will do something stupid and it shows
the finger man the cop shoot the little
girl
all of the local residents just walk up
with weapons and they go after that cop
and then it like camera pans up and he
goes ah like they're no longer going to
tolerate law enforcement
i think it won't be over something like
that but you'll get to the point like
you mentioned a written house situation
we've already seen circumstances where
people have beaten cops where cops are
caught in a riot and then if it gets to
the point where
these riders are unscrupulous and just
literally don't care anymore
then you're going to get a v for
vendetta-like situation there will be a
riot the cop will come out and he'll be
telling people to get away they won't
he'll fire probably a less lethal and
then they'll just start clobbering on
them
so
you you uh we often uh talk about
particularly with people who've
experienced war you know our friend
forrest cooper mentions the people who
are trained in war and who've
experienced it are the ones begging you
to stop because they don't want to see
this happen
i've not been in war i've been in civil
conflict and unrest so precursors too
the worst thing i've seen was people in
egypt shooting at each other with
makeshift they had these pistols that
were like 12 they were
12 gauge i think uh and they would
single shot you break barrel break
action put it in close it bang
and from
atop the hilton i watched someone get
shot killed and then their body was
carried away that was the one time in in
this reporting i've seen someone just
deliberately be killed in front of me
not in front of me like very relatively
close but i was high up so i was safe we
were fair we were all pretty safe
and that experience was like
having covered some of the unrest riots
fires i was i was on west florissant in
ferguson when they were burning down the
entirety of that whole block you drove
your car down the street the fires were
so intense in your car it felt like the
fire was right in front of your face
seeing that
and knowing that's not even warfare
i can't imagine you know like i'll just
ask you like what do you think the
average person would do if they actually
were you know forced into the fray of
people engaging in a firefight in their
in their neighborhood or something yeah
so you know war is uh tends to be a
complex thing but in the primal like the
ancestral version of it's very simple i
mean it's very simple it's it's violence
it's chaos
the people who are trained for war my
peer group who are trained for war go
into war with intent
meeting tasks
uh purpose and objectives
it and so when you have that and and you
understand what that is
it it's demonstrated in this idea of art
of war right we understand how to
operate more
people who have not who people who are
so fragile they can't change their tire
in a fender bender they lose their mind
a simple emergency emergency trauma
they they lose their mind where somebody
actually pays for their life when
something so simple could have been done
that's the world we live in because
we're we're living in that you know
what's really crazy to me so when i did
the uh the hostile environment training
they had to explain to people how to
apply a tourniquet and to put it over
the wound so like
they did this okay so we have a a dummy
here he's got a bleed in his leg and
people were like where does a tourniquet
go they would put it under and they're
like it has to go above and i'm like yes
otherwise it's not stopping the blood
between the heart and the wound yeah i
don't underst that's that's it was crazy
to me that people didn't understand that
we actually had one guy when they showed
a video of a femoral bleed he fainted
and then i was just thinking to myself
like
what would have happened to this guy you
know he's in his neighborhood
violence war conflict breaks out we're
in such a safe era here in the united
states if he saw
a a modicum of the violence that our
troops had experienced he'd be on the
battlefield and he'd look down and just
collapse
like that to me is just
it's just bonkers yeah we i i did you
know deployed all over the world um in
yemen afghanistan iraq pakistan libya
and a lot of the things that people deal
with in those countries they deal with
because that's the way life is
a byproduct of freedom is complacency
and it always has been because we
optimize our life in this democracy and
this sovereignty and it makes our life
really easy but it also makes us very
weak and there is a very specific
percentage of the country from my peer
group who knows what warfare is and then
there's the rest of society one of the
reasons we started fieldcraft survival
is to teach civilians about worst case
scenarios because if you train for the
worst case you're prepared for
everything in between don't train for
the best case train for the worst case
the crazy thing to me is uh
how to conf convey that experience of
actually watching uh you know violence
and trauma to an individual so they
understand why it's so important
to to be prepared
to to unders look there was a story
about a club a fire broke out and
everyone immediately ran to the door and
they all jammed themselves in it and
then i think like people died and
there's a video where a guy when
everyone's running and screaming calmly
walks to the to the fire exit in the
back next to the stage it just walks out
you know i've always known this my whole
life and maybe it's because my dad was a
marine but or as a firefighter actually
and he would say no matter where you are
no whenever you go in a building
wherever you are know your exits and so
my whole life like we'd walk at him a
little kid and he'd be like where's the
fire exit now look i'm like it's right
there anyways you got it and then i hear
these stories of people who are so
unprepared and so complacent they don't
even understand how to leave a building
when the smoke alarm goes off let me
tell you a story man i worked for fusion
which is the abc univision joint venture
no longer exists i'm in the new york
office
and it was really really nice office
they had desks and then they also had
these little diner chairs they had set
up so you could sit in a comfy little
chair to table with your friends and
talk and so i'm sitting there with my
computer and i'm with um my producer who
was working with me
all of a sudden the bright lights start
going off
full blast i grabbed my computer and the
plug i put under my my i get up jump out
of the table and i look over and she's
just in and i'm like come on let's go
and she's like what i'm like the alarm's
going let's go and then she grabs her
stuff and then i look over at everybody
i'm like yo let's go and there's
50 people just sitting there look at me
and then i'm like i'm waiting i get out
of the building we're on like the third
floor i go outside i'm standing outside
i get asked like do you what's going i'm
like the fire alarm went off you get out
of the building what are you
and then
nobody else came out
fire trucks pull up this is in new york
two trucks pull up all the firefighters
jump out run inside
and then a few minutes later one by one
the employees all start walking outside
going like what's happening what's
happening and then i was like did you
guys seriously stay in the building when
the fire alarm went off and you're on it
was like a five-story building or
something like the third floor
turns out there was some kind of gas
leak or or fire threat and it was
remarkable to me that these people were
so comfortable the fire alarm literally
did not persuade them to get out of the
building that's what scares me when we
talk about all of the stuff the petrol
for conflict is that i have witnessed
people sit in the building with the fire
alarms going off full blast
before this happened this is crazy we're
in a different building the power goes
out
the speakers go on
this is an uh an emergency situation has
arisen remain calm stay in the building
and i was like nope and i got out of the
building everybody else stayed turns out
there was a there was a leak in the
basement that had made contact with the
electrical system caused a short huge
fire risk and they didn't want anybody
rushing to the doors and panicking and
leaving so they all just sat there using
battery power on their laptops and i
left the building and went to a cafe to
work i just
i've seen so much of this man as in
ferguson
i'm with the guy he's a he's a veteran
field reporter he's he's fired fully
automatic guns he's been in war and
conflict he's got legit body armor
and
they make the announcement that uh
darren wilson will not be indicted or
something like that and then all of a
sudden
we hear bang bang bang bang bang
i'm on the ground i look to my right
dude's on the ground and i'm like my man
i look to my left and there's a guy from
abc standing there looking around going
those fireworks
and i'm like get down
and then he's like what's happening i
was like do you see anybody with
fireworks no do you see guns okay dude
it's crazy to me man when you're put in
these situations and i'm not even
talking about war i'm like just street
violence riots and stuff but to see how
people act when this stuff goes down i
imagine like in the heat of the chaos
there's very little you can do to
convince un uneducated people about it
so is this why like you're doing this
now so people ahead of time like i was
thinking last night like okay just i've
been thinking i've been in emergency
mode for like weeks it just strikes me
like what if there's an active shooter
what if there's a fire i i should have a
plan with my neighbors with my
environment so what are what steps from
from start to finish if someone were to
experience like an emergency a
life-threatening emergency yeah so all
the things you're describing when we
talk about worst-case scenarios whether
it's natural man-made disaster has to do
with stress they're all like like a a
catastrophe is actually a stressful
event just short in duration of time but
elevated in the actual volume of stress
that you get so a lot of people aren't
prepared for mild stress and you know i
make the joke like if your girlfriend
texts you and says hey i saw you liking
those girls uh yoga pants videos on
instagram how do you react a lot of
people were like what are you talking
about and they get angry and emotional
and they don't know how to react their
palms sweat
and that overreaction is a correlation
to high grade stress how you're going to
react to high grade so a lot of people
in our society they use group think as a
psychology tactic which they don't know
they're doing but it's like if that
person's not moving why would i move
right so we're all sheeple right we're
just not doing anything so the idea is
like identify the threat
observe
pay attention to what it is but like tim
said in a couple examples
physical displacement from the x or the
crisis is the best way to survive so
break your physical body up and away
create distance time and as many
obstacles as you could put in between
but because we're curious we want to
catch catch everything for the gram
we're like what is that noise is that
firecrackers let's walk out with the
phone and catch this on my story on
instagram and then get potentially shot
in the face
not just that but i've seen these
veteran journalists
they do no training and they go into
hostile
environments and they put everybody at
risk yes it happens all the time i've
seen it too i've seen it live
in war with journalists that were with
us sebastian younger is a good example
his one of his best friends who was a
cinematographer on restrepo when he went
was hit by an rpg in libya and killed
not saying they did the wrong thing but
that's that's the potential risk to your
life our society is very fragile very
weak and if you're not getting prepared
now then you should be when you say uh
make distance and time from the x from
the tragedy or from the what
the uh i guess emergency are you saying
like so this is a fire you want physical
distance but you also want when you say
time what is that like you want water
that'll make the fire take longer you
want to create in the distance which is
correlated to time you want to create a
gap space in getting off the x the the
proximity which a lot of the indications
of a catastrophe we sense obviously we
through sound smell taste whatever it is
we we feel it even intuition we're like
hey something might be wrong
follow your intuition one of the reasons
why so many people are getting killed is
because we're complacent but that
relates to our laziness it's like the
idea of like you're in bed watching
netflix with your with your spouse you
hear a loud noise downstairs what do you
immediately do you write it off you're
like oh that's probably the cat uh honey
we don't have a cat oh it's well it's
the neighbor
how's it settling the house is settling
get off your ass
and physically
assess the situation so if you hear
fireworks oh that's fireworks if it
sounds like gunshots
start moving and then figure it out on
the on the on the way out and then read
about it on the news but don't take the
chance that something's gonna happen and
then that's that's obviously the first
part the second part is the technical
proficiency you need and then also the
inoculation of stress most people
forget that like if i teach you to apply
a tourniquet take you three minutes i
mean it's not hard you got a pen yeah is
it a pen a belt material an actual
tourniquet that costs 29.95 on
fieldcraftsrifle.com it's not expensive
um but you get that tourniquet
what we're forgetting in technical
proficiency is there's this inoculation
suppression of stress which means you're
likely going to be in a sympathetic
nervous response fighting and fighting
your body primarily wants to move so you
have to be able to technically react and
do those things
wow under stress we don't have anything
in our society besides jiu-jitsu
combat sports
sports period that allow us to do that
but what are we seeing we're seeing woke
culture making us more soft because it's
everybody gets to participation one one
thing that uh stuck with me for a long
time is this story i read
i was told when i was younger somebody
in my neighborhood these these guys got
into a fight
some guys beat up some guy
a few days later
you know a guy b beats up guy a a few
days later guy a's friend see guys b
and they run up and start wailing on him
and then all of a sudden in the middle
of the pummel one of the dudes pulls out
a knife and goes one two right in the
chest of the dude they're beating up the
other two guys go whoa whoa dude dude
and pull him back like what are you
doing like we were just beating him up
they asked the guy are you okay and he's
like yeah i'm fine and he gets up and
runs turns the corner drops dead
they hit his lung yeah and it was crazy
when uh
i learned about sucking wounds i think
it's right right how simple it would
have been to save that guy's life
relatively simple i mean i i don't know
i'm not an expert on how to i know you
can do the trick with like plastic wrap
and tape on three sides but couldn't
they just like he could have like stuck
his finger in it or plugged it or
something and well it's uh so your your
chest cavity your chest wall is very
it's very
fragile to say the least you take a
puncture when in the chest you're going
to collapse a lung because the negative
pressure and your lung collapses because
it needs that pressure what you're doing
in the chest seal is you're applying it
to that laceration where you've been
compromised in your chest cavity and
it's re-establishing the balance and
that pressure what sounds like to me
that situation is he hits something in
that's vital so he said something in the
the pump house he might have nicked an
artery bled internally which in that
case he would need a chest tube or he
would need you know upgraded levels of
care and there might not have been a
thing he could have done so at least the
story is we were told that it caused a
sucking wound so i don't maybe my
understanding of what happened was wrong
yeah but in that circumstance you think
it was just they couldn't do anything
about it yeah likely he got stuck in in
the pump house or a major artery off of
the the branch of the heart that he bled
internally because when you a sucking
chest wound is going to help with
circulation and circulation and
respiration so when you apply that
like i've i've treated guys in real life
where the guy had been has a laceration
in his chest he has a second chest and
he can't breathe he's completely pale
and and then you put a a a piece of
plastic basically it's got hydra tape
that's on it and you put it on his chest
and he immediately comes back because
he's laying his lung inflating he's like
oh my god like holy crap that was crazy
well when somebody's bleeding internally
that's one of the hardest things to stop
it's it's how you kill big game elk or
deer you should hit him in the chest
cavity in the pump house and you should
hope to double lung them and they bleed
out immediately dead in 30 seconds i got
i got to say man you know
i always tell people have some emergency
food have some emergency water um have
you should have a go bag clothes in it
all the supplies i would i would
probably stress that people probably
look into your stuff and and figure out
the basics because i just watched a
fight video
it's on reddit
dudes are fighting in the street
everyone's laughing
and cheering and then one guy takes a
swing dude ducks comes up returns the
hook damn guy just hits the deck
woman runs up to him and starts shaking
his head violently and i'm like she's
gonna paralyze that guy yeah people
don't know anything about this it's
crazy watching videos so often of people
if they just were told one sentence
could save a life crazy man it's crazy
how simple it is it's very simple yeah
you mentioned stress management earlier
in jiu jitsu i've often thought and been
talking to people that also think that
the police could benefit from taking jiu
jitsu at least being like a purple belt
or something in jiu-jitsu that they
could manage stress better i hadn't
thought that of combat sports as a way
to like while you were talking i was
like oh working out if the more
muscularly you know beat up i am the
more i'll be able to handle a fire or an
invasion or something that's that's
resilience we call that resilience right
it's your ability to bounce back through
adversity in difficult circumstances the
best way to do that which you know leah
stumpf and andy stumpf who are good
friends of mine who who teach this
through their dojo and kalispell the
idea is when you're fighting and
combating a person i'm 240 pounds six
foot one i'm a big asian dude i have a
diverse combatives background i step in
a ring with a black belt and brazilian
jiu jitsu 150 pound dude he will
pretzel-roll me in half
getting beat by another human being in a
physical confrontation is very humbling
because the idea that you would increase
your sympathetic nervous response get
more aggressive louder more angry is all
the things that's going to get you
choked out faster so you have to be calm
you have to concentrate on your
breathing you have to rely on technical
proficiency and if you don't manage your
stress you'll just get choked out and
that's the benefit of jiu jitsu i think
on a massive scale which uh andy has
talked about this uh all the guys that
i'm in my same circle have talked about
how every law enforcement officer should
be trained at a at a minimum in jiu
jitsu uh a grant uh greg anderson a
buddy of mine in washington state runs a
program as a former police officer where
they're training law enforcement
officers to be
better at jiu jitsu to make them
prepared for what they see in the
streets so you're trying to train
regular people and all this stuff
i mean that sounds like it would be a
really really great thing
if we had if the every single person in
this country had basic survival skills
and preparedness skills it would make us
i mean
just
particularly
well prepared for any kind of invasion
or conflict or war or anything like that
yeah but i wonder why it is that uh
government institutions would oppose
that well here here's why
you outsource everything to the
government because we have this
collaborative social agreement this
non-written contract we're going to pay
taxes so we're going to outsource health
care we're going to out source first
response we're going to outsource
everything to make our life more
convenient so when you empower yourself
which is what we're teaching we're not
just teaching preparedness we're
teaching self-reliance and that is
offensive for a government who wants
control and power the less power they
have the more you cut the umbilical cord
the more opposed they are to that it ha
it's there's classic cases of it
obviously i was going to ask if you have
a lot of teachers who reach out to you
because i hate to say it but stress
management i know obviously like we
could be talking about school shootings
but even just like i went to a high
school where we would have occasionally
kids od in the classroom like if you're
in a scenario with unpredictable people
even if they're not inherently dangerous
to you being able to manage your
response to them and know how to react
and love scenarios seems like a really
valuable tool yeah we're starting so
we're starting a kids program this year
with
our family director of preparedness
amber we started teaching women and a
lot of those women were teachers and a
lot of those women were single moms and
they showed up and were like why are you
here it's like well because we want to
know how to be prepared too because it
seems like to be like a tactical
industry thing but normal people want to
know how to manage stress how to apply a
tourniquet how how to react in an active
shooting so you know we were very
critical of you of all day and all the
things that that went wrong because we
want to make the wrong
right in the future and we've gotten a
huge response from teachers in fact my
training director uh
sean kirkwood and kevin owens who are
both veteran green berets they are
working with our law enforcement
instructors because we a green beret
teaching um self-defense isn't the best
tactic always right we kill and capture
bad guys we don't we don't do the legal
law enforcement thing we we deploy these
law enforcement officers all over the
country to teach
these teachers and teach these uh
resource officers how to be better
prepared and that's what we need
ultimately because the superpower we are
i think the second amendment makes us a
superpower which makes us not ukraine
that's why you gotta subsidize ukraine
with billions of dollars and all the
assets to bear america is a superpower
because of the constitutional freedoms
that we have but also our current
capability the nra which i am not an
advocate of the nra outside of their
lobbying to support constitutional of
security
when you look at the nra and why it
stood up it stood up post-civil war 18
1840 or 1861-64
civil war
i think it stood up in 65 i might be
wrong but when you look at why they
stood up it's because they wanted to
make um they wanted to make the civilian
populist better prepared to defend
themselves because they were shooting
flint locks from hips or didn't know how
to load it we were a national superpower
because of that and i think that's
ultimately what we are we as a as a
population the more prepared we are the
better capable we are against russia
china north korea iran if they wanted to
ban together and take this country over
it'd be an easy fight yeah there's a gun
behind every blade of grass it was 1871
1871 as well
i think also it makes people less afraid
of each other when you're comfortable or
confident in your ability to defend
yourself there's less reason to fear
donald trump or random guy down the
street that might be armed you know like
it's it's a lot easier to i don't know
no you're we we see that on the range
when people show up you have all
backgrounds it's not tactical guys
showing up to our ranges it's like
mothers fathers uh teenage uh you know
18 19 year old young people who want to
be better prepared when you see that in
them coming together the the second and
third order effects of all this
when people come together trying to be
better prepared they start building
community and they start going they
don't they don't go oh you're a
republican or you're a democrat they go
oh you want to be prepared too like i
don't care what your background is or
who you politically affiliate with i'm
on that same page let's do this together
and protect our family let's learn a
skill and and that's the biggest
component that we've made is this idea
of bringing people together over a
commonality which is being best prepared
and it's better for you if your
neighbors are prepared especially if you
have a positive relationship with them
right like when we grew up i assume all
of us knew what community watches were
right you had a community watch that
would watch out for each other and you
hated like the pesky old lady my dad we
used to talk about it like god she's
always talking about what's new what's
different what changes in that
environment now we live in a society
where you pull up and you see your
neighbor um checking his mouth and
you're scowling because you're like who
is this like that's our neighbor honey
like you know oh yeah but you know why
community watch went away
we had someone on the show talked about
this that if you form a community watch
group anything you do now is conspiracy
so everybody like all lawyers are
telling people don't be involved high
liability conspiracy yeah i get it yeah
yeah if i tell you in your bedroom i'm
like hey i'm thinking about starting a
company that's a conspiracy no no no
what they're saying is
if you ever if you're in a community
watch group and then one guy goes out
and someone is is breaks into a building
and they get into a fight and the cr and
the the burglar the robber gets killed
they will say
if you can't justify the killing it was
a conspiracy to commit murder and the
other members of the community watch are
involved wow when did that start
happening well someone talked about on
the show several months ago so i don't
know exactly when it started happening
but that sounds like i could see it i
could see that it would be some kind of
legal precedence where
it increased the liability the local
district attorneys were like whoa whoa
whoa we can't manage this because like
american contingency we try to
co-cooperate with local sheriff's
departments because if we are the first
on the scene of an accident
how can we best support and facilitate a
first responder about to come in if i if
i know and i'm trained how to identify a
threat or identify a casualty and can
facilitate a law enforcement officer
who's coming in to do the rescuing or do
do the facilitation of rescue then i am
an asset to that community but again the
district attorney comes in they have a
political affiliation and they go oh
this is too much liability you do your
job and just live in your life and let
us do our job which is controlling your
life and that's threatening i mean
having chickens having a homestead
growing your own food is threatening to
people in this country they said
facebook said canning was extremist
what we were we were just making i got
deleted for a canning video because it
was seen as extreme
our when we started this company every
video that we did that was uh even
remotely related to self-reliance was
seen as extreme and it was deleted from
facebook the people who taught me most
about suffering lines were my uh
step-grandparents who are just like
older white people from texas who have
like canning stuff and some horses yeah
like we we uh we grew some vegetables we
wanted we have berries so we've got a
good like three or four weeks of berry
season out here so you gotta preserve
them and you know you gotta know how to
can because if you don't do it right it
can create botulism and it can kill you
when you try to eat the canned food you
gotta know how to spoil the things you
do yeah i love it i geek out on the
homesteading stuff it's some of the
stuff that we teach
but the whole idea is going to only help
the government because it's less stress
and strain but if you look at what the
government's tactics are it's to create
more reliance because if you are if you
are dependent on solely on their
finances their government health care
systems and all the things then they
have you they have you hooked they have
your vote because they have you hooked
any displacement from that is
threatening by by the government we're
gonna oh she's gonna say does your group
get accused of like cultivating
vigilantism is that like one of the
fears that you guys are going to think
that you're better than law enforcement
100 i mean that that's the title militia
that's that's as described by the
government of who we are and and
and people are like oh it's no big deal
they just called you a name no when you
designate somebody a name in the
government that comes with authorities
those authorities come from lines of
funding that means execution orders to
do surveillance and all this other stuff
so it gets more deeply seated in the
weeds when they title you a militia and
we most certainly are not we're a
community of americans that just want
the best we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the url to this link
wherever you can if you really do like
the show just share the show in general
and head over to timcast.com become a
member because we're going to have that
uncensored members only after show
coming up at 11 p.m let's read we got
evan grant who says tim's wrong about
apps listening on conversations i've
literally run tests to have people
mention products to me while my phone's
out not doing any searches and then
checking ads
i don't know what you mean about me
being wrong are you saying that i'm
wrong when i say they're probably not
listening to you it's just predicting
your behavior
so
you've heard people say that like
they'll say something near their phone
and then their phone will do an
advertisement for it
the claim is that they're not really
listening to you but that the algorithms
can predict your behavior so well that
they pre you know that it seems like
they're listening to you so the example
we gave the other day is
father sees a bunch of letters come in
the uh advertisements in the mail for
pregnancy gear and stuff from target to
his daughter and he's like he calls them
up like why are you sending maternity
stuff to my teenage daughter and they're
like it's just an algorithm based on
what you search for we don't know
turns out the daughter wasn't searching
for pregnancy stuff she was searching
for stuff like why do i feel this way
do i need you know nausea medicine or
something and the algorithm knew that
based on the things she was doing and
when she was doing it she was probably
pregnant because it can see
a hundred million women all saying the
exact same things when they get pregnant
however i will add i was talking with
when we're talking with jack posobic on
the show
we mentioned book it book it was the old
program remember pizza hut i don't know
i don't know how old you how old you 42
42. so you had book it when you were a
kid right yeah you'd read the book at
school and then you get a free donut you
get a pizza
i got an advertisement for a booking
agency that would that said book it and
it was their tagline
and i saw it and i was like okay that
makes no sense
in what context would anything
book it doesn't exist anymore so the
only thing it could show me was an ad
for travel called bookit dude it they're
listening okay google stop alexa stop
those machines are listening to you
i think there's one in here right now
it's also that they figure out like if
you're sharing the wireless network with
someone and they're researching a topic
it will also serve those ads to your
phone right users are on the same
network did anybody here google search
book it
my google thing is on right now by the
way sorry you just you just told it to
turn it on yeah i told it to stop but i
guess that's not the turn off it was
like you yes you asked for me hello
isn't that mike i can turn on your
machine if you're listening to me at
home that's crazy my point here is
jack was talking about pizza hut
nationalism have you ever heard him talk
about that jackpot
and referencing a program that doesn't
exist anymore you should not get an
advertisement for it
i got an ad in big blue bold letters
that said book it and i was like get out
of here dude i don't travel there's no
reason for me to be i i'm here for 16
hours every day morning and night doing
this show almost no travel there is
nothing in my search that i am doing
that suggests any kind of travel the
only way this could have been delivered
to me is because it was listening to me
when i said book it yeah and it the the
machine assumed book it meant book the
travel
when i was talking about a reading
program
because there's no more reading program
the only ad it could serve me was travel
i was crazy traveling with friends once
and we all grew up in connecticut and if
you're from connecticut you probably
know what bean boots are which are
they're an ll bean product they're just
really popular and they were telling me
that like one of my friends had gone to
school in chicago and someone had
recognized her as being from new england
because she was wearing these yellow
bean boots i have never searched for
them in my life i don't own them i don't
i don't follow l bean or anything like
that on social media my phone was in a
separate room charging i walked in the
first ad serving was for l bean boots i
remember i was talking to someone on
facebook messenger
and then i was talking to someone in
person at the time while on messenger
and then all of a sudden a little thing
popped up for the ad about what we were
talking about we're talking about going
to like you know who knows or whatever
pizzeria knows and then also the thing
popped up and i was like
people in the chat are like ian you
turned my tv off
i know my correctional machine just all
right let's let's read some more
all right let's see george
frederelli says so glad mike is on to
tell his story and also how the fbi is
targeting american contingency hot damn
hey mike please talk about your time in
the old guard and the tomb of the
unknown soldier oh yeah
so big shout out to uh my buddy khan
had a third infantry uh soldier who's
going to ranger assessment really soon
he
he shouted out to me and said hey you
want to get a tour and i had some tomb
guards reach out to me and say hey we'll
give you a tour of the quarters which is
in the middle of arlington national
cemetery so back when you know sir major
glover was a private i was an e1 17
years old i went to the old guard as my
first stint prior to 9 11 happen and
this is 1997
and one of the hardest things that you
could do in the military period was try
out to be a guard at the tomb of the
unowns so it's been guarded 24 hours a
day by the army since 1948 it's right
down the road in the middle of arlington
cemetery as the world war one world war
ii korean vietnam unknowns they
disinterred the vietnam unknown because
they identified them as an air force
pilot named major michael blassie uh he
since was uh disinterred and buried in
his home state of missouri
and then um i was a guard there from
1998 to 2000 prior to 9 11 happening so
as bad badge holder number four seven
zero
and um
right now they're at 701 for the badge
holders it's the second hardest badge to
get in the military besides the
astronauts badge and took me nine months
to earn my tomb identification badge and
was the most difficult thing that i did
in the military of all the things what
do you have to do you have to guard the
tomb of the unknowns on a on a cycle or
a schedule based on your relief and
there's three reliefs based on height
and you do that 24 hours a day seven
days a week since
but how do you earn the badge like you
go through a process so you have to you
have to memorize 20 plus pages of
knowledge on the on arlington national
cemetery there's uniform inspections uh
my standard will remain perfection is
line six of the sentinels creed
that whole methodology is ingrained into
you as a tomb guard where you have to be
perfect so it was a it was a crazy deal
being so young and doing that but it's
what established my whole military
career so uh ian kinney said something i
was just reading it while you guys were
talking says tim you should see what
media bias fact check says about timcast
i think you'll be upset and possibly
will want to send them a letter
absolutely not i'm i think it's actually
amazing so uh media's bias fact check
if you've ever heard of them they tell
you if it's left or right um they call
us rightwing at timcast.com
i do think that's silly considering
timcast.com is like 80 not political so
it's like cast castle is not pop culture
crisis is not inverted world is not
chicken city is certainly not i hope
they are the most political part what
are you talking about it is true yeah
when roberto so do you know the politics
roberto um was found guilty
of sex crimes
so he's been sentenced to the penal
colony of cocktown with 20 other
roosters yeah and roberto jr has assumed
the role of sheriff of chicken city
chicken tenders that's your contenders
but media buys factcheck says
factual reporting
very high
press freedom rank mostly free
medium traffic with high credibility oh
it's fantastic sounds great yeah but
your right wing i mean they can call
whatever they want um
it's it's weird that they're they're uh
they say due to story selection
and it's like
okay i guess i mean like we report on
hearing aids you know the bind
administration signed you did that right
that was me like i'm not sure that's
right we were i mean i really think that
our reporting is incredibly mixed and
part of that is because our journalists
have a lot of interest like they are not
in and of themselves all in one rabbit
hole i mean we we kind of cover
everything really but i don't care if
they can again i think we're the coolest
news sites
they can call me right wing i'm not
gonna get mad about that they said we
were highly highly high credibility and
green like big letters i'm like oh there
you go that's right we are we are we
have higher standards than news guard
that is true yeah then even even
newsguard yeah
nick conant says i asked lauren today
why she wasn't drinking a thousand
dollar whiskey in a paper cup in her
live stream her response i only drink
other people's thousand dollar worth
true to form so are you familiar with
papi uh so just like a thousand dollars
oh yeah pappy oh yes lauren lauren
southern was here and she grabbed a
paper cup and asked if she'd have
whiskey said sure and she was pouring it
in the cup and drinking from it and i
didn't notice and then someone pointed
out and then i was like lauren are you
drinking the thousand dollar whiskey of
a paper cup and she's like is that how
much it is i don't know like what
all the all of these are humbling
the whiskey people were like no give her
crown royal or something have a
chronological bottle oh man there was a
guy who a restaurant owner who got so
frustrated with how difficult it is to
get pappy and there's like an allotment
that he started uh giving out at cost
and then one year he gave it out as
jello shots and then he stopped getting
a lot of pappy van wyk ooh smart
all right raymond g stanley jr says
brian stelter is a reliable source like
antifa is anti-fascist like abortion is
healthcare like men can get pregnant
like biden is the great unifier like
fiery is mostly peaceful like tim has
hair
brilliant
bravo good sir
yep all right
triton54 says would give anything to see
mike in a room with brandon tatum
discussing evaldi everyone needs to
watch mike's take on the uvalde response
that green beret made this navy chief
stand at attention for 90 minutes
straight
what was that about well it's me calling
out yvaldi and i i think that the issue
where they're mentioning brandon is he
was he was backing him because he's back
in the blue he's a former sheriff's
officer and that's what you do when you
when you're taking care of your tribe
but i consider law enforcement officers
because i train them for a living as
part of my job
brothers and sisters
and i want to make sure that i'm always
doing right by them so doing right by
them means criticizing them when they're
wrong and so for 90 minutes i went
through the video that was released the
cctv camera had the breakdown timeline
with the cctv camera and went minute by
minute through what was right and what
was
95 wrong where did can people find that
video it's on my youtube channel on uh
we have two youtube channels the
fieldcraft survival channel and uh mike
glover actual i believe that one's on
the fieldcraft survival channel
it's got a couple million views a lot of
people who are heated and talking about
it but i think that's a good thing
because
if you could extract anything good it's
we should never make that mistake ever
ever ever again and it also is a
testament to
law enforcement failures but law
enforcement successes because it wasn't
for the vortech operators whose job by
the way is not responding to active
shootings in schools they do border
patrol and and and react to crisis in
border on the on the uh border they on
their own accord went in there like
heroes and got in a gunfight with a bad
guy that killed 19 kids on their own
accord because they're a part of that
community to a testament to everything
you are working on whatever you call for
yes they were taking care of their own
community and if it wasn't for those
guys there'd be more children
potentially done all right matt zarella
says tim please hire brian stelter and
make him wash your car while dressed
like biff at the end of back to the
future
i get that because i watch back the
future a little bit of humility for
brian is going to go a long way right
now i don't know you know what i don't
know what's he going to do just have
something like that he'll never i can't
imagine well
some blog buzzfeed'll hinder him i guess
he'll like get a professorship somewhere
he's going to be okay yeah i don't worry
about him i have to say
matthew velasquez says hello tim what
are mike's thoughts about the rooftop
koreans in california circa 92
oh yes
so um
yeah the rooftop koreans is you know i
my mom and had friends who lived in la
at that time koreatown was radically um
invaded by a whole bunch of radical
protesters that were violent and extreme
who killed multiple people and wounded a
lot of people injured a lot of people
the rooftop koreans were taking care of
their businesses but protecting their
lives and self-defense it's the great
thing about the second amendment that
allows you to do that before all the
radical gun laws came to california
with just an interesting note
i want to remind people when you can do
this research
gun control came from government
institutions wanting to counter the
black panthers in the 1970s and 80s
specifically under reagan when reagan
was the president those laws were
expanded into texas and that became gun
control because they were fearful of
law-abiding citizens who happened to be
black protesting with firearms around
government buildings and that started
the snowball rolling downhill so when
you're voting for these things when
you're thinking about these things
when you look at your real rights just
remember where that started and any of
those infringements on those rights uh
started with the black panther
movement one thing that bums me out with
the culture war stuff is um
i tweeted something about second
amendment absolute have your guns and
then i got this leftist response and
they were like yeah but i don't hear you
saying you know black people should have
guns your position is totally fake and i
responded with i think every single
black person in this country should be
walking around with an ar-15 if they so
choose i think the black panther should
be armed to the teeth and then he
responded with based
and then i'm like yes like bro like i
don't care from the left or the right i
think everybody has a right keep and
bear arms i don't know why they assume
that about us or other people's
positions that like we don't want the
black panthers to be armed the second
amendment bro yeah they should all have
guns and like the the what is it the um
not effing around coalition you know
those guys yes yeah yeah they had some
misfires which is
you know come on guys training couple
accidental discharges accidental
discharges there yeah sorry not misfires
but i'm like i watch that video and i'm
like
i dig it like cool man they're like
walking around they're all armed they're
doing their thing yep right on man
that's that's they're not hurting
anybody they're peacefully protesting
absolutely now the accidental discharges
is a problem
but but like it's fine to call
accidental discharges i mean they should
never have keeping arms maybe those guys
who should you know maybe at that regard
there should be
you know i don't know is that it's a
criminal charge right i believe right
ferd yeah it's fire it's basically
firing a a firearm in public yeah yeah
yeah yeah so look i understand that
but uh i watch these videos with these
guys and they're pretty aggressive but
hey man i got no beef yeah no i was
thinking last night i'll badass this
country is and one of the great things
is the individualism the ability to kind
of not have the state looking down your
back because it's in those times of
silence and solitude where you can
create great things where you're not
interrupted by
outside forces this is amazing
opportunity yeah we'll try and write
some more super chats we've got martin
edgar he says the viewing of pictures
and video of combat is nothing like
actually experiencing experiencing it
being there is 100 times worse from a
gulf war and somalia vet thank you for
your service mike 24 id 3ce victory
division
what do you
without i want to ask you all about your
experience in the war we don't have time
for that on this show tonight obviously
but like what was the biggest difference
in the perception of what it was going
to be and then what it was in reality
when you were there i i think the
effects on innocent people right you you
fight an insurgency which is the most
difficult thing to fight it's not
conventional forces going head-to-head
in an open field like the civil war it
is literally going door-to-door and then
going is that guy going to kill me is
that guy a bad guy or is that an
innocent person and innocent people are
affected by it so when people talk about
civil war what they're really talking
about is an insurgency where you can't
identify a friend from foe or the person
that's waving you at you friendly that
one second is throwing a grenade into
your vehicle the second so that is very
difficult to manage and for me the most
difficult thing in my nine trips and
four and a half years to war
was
seeing innocent children and women
affected by that
the the men middle-aged males who were
aggressively
going after us in a war free game but
you'll never be in a conclusive battle
just you and bad guys toe to toe all of
these bad guys are surrounded using them
as human shields by their children and
and they're women and it's disgusting to
see that but that's the horrific side of
war i think one of the uh
and this is just a video i saw one of
the most brutal videos was a father
holding his son who had died in you know
street conflict and the sound that man
made it's just like
man
you know these these these uh larpers
these antifa people who want a
revolution are going to be the first
ones crying and begging for
the these people who who pretend to want
this revolution so as soon as they get
what they want they'll be begging for an
authoritarian regime to take over and
bring back stability by any means
necessary they will cry and beg it was a
mistake we didn't mean it we mean it
they call it calm they want calm they
don't talk about peace they talk about
calm
just want to be able to walk down the
street pick up a loaf of bread go back
home and share with your family and not
have to worry about getting
hit by shrapnel or an ied
let's see below few says last night you
guys talked about how infrequently men
cry compared to women i had a pretty
good streak going until you started
reading detransitioning perspectives on
reddit very powerful episode
yeah that was the members only thing we
did last night we were talking about um
these issues and we pulled up the d
trans subreddit where it's mostly young
women talking about how they were misled
and how they regret this and their lives
are destroyed the terrifying thing is
how some of these people are talking
about taking their own lives and
you know we want we want desperately to
avoid all of that but
we got we got dark days in this country
man this you know
all right kg seath says jocko willink on
joe rogan said cops should be trained in
jiu jitsu
yes
what belt level do you think would be
sufficient for an officer blue at a
minimum so there's white and then blue
which is
general proficiency both top and bottom
so you understand leverage and control i
think at a minimum it needs to be blue
and i think the experts including jocko
willing who is an expert um would say
the same would you have it done like at
the police academy level or is it
something that like you'd have to
continuously pursue like with the
fitness test good point i mean the
biggest deficiency in
obviously going after defunding the
police officers is budgets and
constraints that are within the
department and when i tell people as i
did in the military i wasn't a great
operator in special operations because
the military or the institution made me
such i went out on my own time and went
to jiu jitsu dojos shot competitions on
the side and did all these things that
made me better so i would say
yes part of that should be
the institutional
academy or patrol academy but they
should
not use that as a crutch and do it on
their own being more self-reliant all
right ayazia fraser says no tim fiddles
are quite difficult to play trump plays
them like the cheap kazoos they are uh
they're also expensive yeah so uh good
good point
fair point uh point taken and accepted i
just can't get over it like being you
tells me how good i am like what yeah
how talented i am incredibly talented
trump's so great man
he does he does uh
he has these lines that you're just like
no one in the world would script this
for you i just whoever would try to
recreate a trump speech i i just
i can't imagine what that task must be
like all right all right manifest
destiny says tim if you call bourbon
whiskey one more time i'm going to
declare a kentucky fatwa on you
all right all right point taken point
taken
all right we got we got way too many
super chats today but i really
appreciate it guys
um aaron
sagno says tim huge fan and paid member
thanks for inspiring me i'm currently
running for city council in tulsa
oklahoma i've been going door-to-door in
my don't snake me bro t-shirt and it's
working nice that's right man
the machine is terrified
that the culture is shifting to such a
degree you know what you know what i
noticed something today
i hate netflix
i just finished watching lock and key
have you guys heard of that show
no
three seasons and they've canceled it
and that's it for me i am done with
netflix i like that show the third
season sucked and i was like that's a
bummer they cancelled the show
they run all of these shows for two
seasons and then cancel them out right i
wonder why that is they're also charging
now what like 20 bucks a month or
something they're putting commercials in
don't they want to crack down on
password sharing too yeah it's like
their famous threat a big part of it is
probably because the actors contracts
are up and they're going to have to get
and renegotiate 10x maybe they want to
keep my mind my point is
i wonder just nobody's watching their
shows anymore like the culture is
decaying but then i look at the daily
wires hiring a disney executive to be
their their cmo i think chief cmo and uh
like their influence is taking over i
wonder if the old guard is already
doomed and we're just watching them
slowly now slump off and fade into uh
into the distance and i was realizing
this i'm watching netflix and i'm like
all of these shows were canceled like
why are you showing me shows with no
resolution i'm not going to watch 10
episodes of a show and then but they
canceled it too bad that's what that's
lame
and that's what netflix is right now so
i'm looking at what's going on and i'm
just like
yo uh
the culture war we are winning it and
they're panicking over it they're going
after trump they're going after jones
they're freaking out
i think there may be dark days ahead for
sure but it's a transition to a new
world order man and we're involved we're
transitioning it as we speak it's a
great debate yeah
steve graves radio says i believe a
civil war is avoidable if enough regular
people speak up and express their honest
opinion that is why i took your advice
and created a youtube channel called
steve graves radio very grateful to any
feedback and subscriptions uh glad to
hear it man
yeah that's the unfortunate thing we
talk about it quite a bit people who are
uh who are afraid to share their views
because the machine will punish them and
it's like but the like it's a paradox
the only
the only reason the machine will come
after you for speaking up for your
opinion is because no one does
if literally right now every single
trump supporter just came out and put a
trump flag on their lawn
the machine would invert all of a sudden
all the democrats would be like
i was always a trump supporter because
they see the widespread popularity of
the city i don't know if if signage is
the way to go that's kind of a virtue
signal i think making a [ __ ] channel
and speaking your mind is is number one
see i think you should also just have
these conversations honestly with people
around you i think so often people avoid
talking about not even politics just
like things you believe in your values
with your friends and neighbors because
you're afraid of seeming different or
isolating them or
maybe making them feel judged which is
obviously a sin
you know to a certain extent you just
need to both live your values and be
open about your values so people who may
not share them can act talk to you about
them in a reasonable way i think it's
great if you want to make it out online
platform to to reach other people but
really it should start at the building
block which is like on your street in
your community
i guess we were both right yeah
okay i'm open to signs i'm not saying
don't do it but i think that's also a
way for deep state to target people if
they go around they just find all those
yeah and i'm not like you don't have to
put a sign in your heart but i do think
that like if you don't feel like you can
tell the people you think are your
closest friends who you voted for and
discuss openly like when you have
differences of opinion then you are
probably not being honest with the
people around you you're never going to
be able to have authentic progress
without that
dude the internet video changes stuff so
rapidly it happens so fast when a lot of
people start doing it and community just
comes out of it it's great
that's the best part of this whole thing
is like even these long-form discussions
from four different people from
different walks of life like people are
more interested in that because it feels
more real because it is real
versus you know talking heads
telling talking points like who wants to
see that anymore the future of
i think media across the board is what
this is and different forms of it which
i which i love that's what i digest i
don't even i don't subscribe anymore to
institutions especially woke ones that
have an agenda i'm more interested in
free thought and ideas and then and then
collecting those people like even the
daily wire because they have diversity
and then collecting all that and then
absorbing it all right ladies and
gentlemen if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show if you really do like it head over
to timcast.com we're gonna have the
uncensored after show coming up at about
11 p.m plus all of our other shows you
can follow the show at tim cast irl you
can follow me at tim cast mike do you
want to shout anything out you know just
fill crosston rival.com american
contingency.com all of our content we do
for free like it's the content release
the podcast all the things that we do is
to get you informed and educate you to
to provide you value if you see value
then dig deeper in the weeds right on
i'm hannah claire brimlo i'm a writer
for timcast.com i recommend you check it
out every day for your news updates you
can follow me on instagram hannah claire
dot b thanks so much please follow me uh
go through to me from ian crossland.net
if you want to follow me on social media
fantastic mike it was really great to
see you man thank you so much if people
want to follow you i know they can
follow you personally on twitter uh
michael mike a glover1 and then mike.a
dot glover on on instagram yeah great
stuff see you later thank you guys all
so much for tuning in thank you mike
very much for coming this evening you
guys can follow me on twitter and
mines.com at sourpatchlids as well as
sourpatulits.me we will see all of you
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out
bye guys
you